[Music]
this was the moment police moved in to
take back control of ottawa's streets
protesters have occupied the area
outside parliament for nearly three
weeks
officers used their new powers under the
emergencies act to arrest truckers and
other protesters who refused to leave
this is disgusting
this is absolutely ridiculous
arresting people at a peaceful assembly
that we have the right to be here even
with the emergency act
canadian truckers calling themselves the
freedom convoy accuse the authorities of
overreacting
i negotiated on behalf of the truckers a
peaceful retreat
the police promised they would not
attack they would let them retreat
peacefully they broke the deal because
there's no leadership or they're intent
on violence that's what they want
protest leader tamara lytch was among
scores arrested they've been
demonstrating against a rule that
requires truckers to be vaccinated to
cross the u.s border
the government says the illegal blockade
and occupation is a threat to peace
order and good government
today
our economy and our democracy
are facing a serious and foreign funded
threat
these illegal blockades and occupations
cannot be allowed to usurp the authority
of democratically elected governments
[Music]
[Applause]
police say they'll work around the clock
to clear the city's downtown area
we're in control of the situation on the
ground and continue to push forward to
clear our streets
this methodical and well-resourced plan
will take time and we are here to see it
through to a safe ending
many truckers left voluntarily but those
remaining insist they won't move until
the coveted vaccine requirement to cross
the u.s border is removed
victoria gayton b al jazeera